hi
uh my name is thomas caswell and thank
you for watching my pi data global 2020
uh talk today i will be telling you
about
the why you should be thinking about the
separation of scales and so the
separation of concerns
uh when you design your software
so first a little bit about myself i'm
trained as a physicist
um particularly an experimental softness
matter physicist
uh in grad school i worked on a
combination of
um a morph jammed amorphous system which
asset glass analogs and i also worked on
the fluid dynamics of the vapor layer
below align and frost
drop some of the some of the data from
that is shown below
but what i learned in grad school is
that i'm the thing i'm most passionate
about is building software
to enable science and to build software
for scientists to do
better science more easily and to that
end i'm now
currently staff at brookhaven national
lab at nsls2
where as part of a team idea i maintain
and develop
tools for data acquisition management
and analysis
for use in the synchrotron community i'm
also the current project lead of
matplotlib
i like to start with acknowledgements of
how i got to where tell how i got here
um
for something to thank michael dropboom
and the whole mad potluck team
for uh teaching me a lot of what i
know and training me from a
a stereotypical cowboy physics grad
student
to someone who can at least
produces usable software for others
i'd also like to thank dan allen and ken
lauer who were
who are colleagues from brookhaven
national lab although ken has since
moved to slack
at stanford they were in the trenches
with me
as we built out a lot of the initial
version of the software we
maintain at sls2 and
we learned a lot along the way and
finally i'd like
i'd like to thank my wife dora who heard
many early versions of this talk and
provided valuable feedback
and without her support i would not be
able to do the amount of open source
work
that i do so
in computers
we live in a very layered system you
know one might say an onion
so if we start filling the layers back
and start from let's say i want to write
some python
uh that's now that's text that python
that text gets parsed into us
into a abstract syntax tree which is
eventually converted to bytecode
which is then run on the c python
virtual machine
which turns out that's a c program which
uses some c libraries and some 4chan
libraries
uh particularly if you're using numpy or
pandas and
or scipy
but c programs are compiled to machine
code
machine code is what drives the digital
circuits of a cpu of the cpu
digital circuits are made up out of
transistors uh but transistors are
you know when you look deep enough just
very carefully dope silicon
um and for them for that silicon and the
doping to behave
as we as we need for it to be
transistors that relies on a lot of
details of the crystal structure of
the silicon and like the electronic
structure of the electrons in that
crystal
um you know in the band gap and there's
a lot there's a lot of very interesting
physics there
um you know and that whole thing is made
up of
atoms and electrons and then atoms
themselves are made up of
you know protons neutrons quarks gluons
and the whole trend
to hold all those friends and then
uh at this point we've run out of space
on the slide
and run up to the edge of uh physics
understanding
but there's a 21 billion or 21 billion
euro
proposal to build the upgrade to lhc
uh to to try to go the next layer down
so this idea of layers is not
uh is not new in computer science right
this has been with us
you know almost from the beginning um to
quote dijkstra
from a book he published in 1976
uh you're discussing what it means to
do programming uh and i will end quote
in other words when asked to produce one
or more results it is usual to
generalize the problem and to consider
these results
as specific instances of the wider class
but it's no good to just say everything
is a special instance of something more
general
if we want to follow such approach we
have two obligations first
we have to be quite specific as to how
we generalize i
we have to choose our water class
carefully and to define it explicitly
because the argument has to apply to
that whole class second
we have to choose invent if you wish a
generalization that is helpful to our
purpose
um
i think uh this notion so it's
having received our marching orders
let's go ahead and build some layer you
know build some layers
i think this notion of building layers
or new abstractions
applies to everyone who works with
computers right this isn't just for
people who develop low-level libraries
or people who do system level stuff
if you do anything where you tell the
you give the computer a list of
instructions and then give that
the set of instructors a new name you
know it could be be it
um typing any code at all in any form
you're using click and drag programming
configuring filters in your email client
putting a formula in excel
any of that you are creating abstraction
layer
and like no like i'm not kidding i think
you've taken the tools you had available
and built a new set of tools that is
better suited to your needs
and solves your problems better than uh
than the the base tools you had and that
this this
process of building new layers on top of
the layers we have
is in some sense fundamental to what it
is to be a developer
um unless you go doing this i'm going to
propose a couple questions you should
keep in mind
uh during the design process
is the first is you should think what
level is your
is what you're working on targeting if
this is something is this something
target that's targeted to be used
directly by
a human in that case you you know you
probably should
eat all you know be very good at
exception handling that make sure it
never makes it out
be very forgiving about the inputs bake
in as many assumptions as you need to
make that tool
as simple for the human to use as
possible
on the other hand if you're writing code
that's something that's going to be used
someplace deeper in the stack and you
expect to be extended
by other code then you probably want to
have crankier interfaces that are you
know
that have stricter validation that will
re-raise exceptions
um second question i think is critical
to think about is
how does the information flow through
your code right what parts of your code
need to know what information when
and how how does that
information move between the parts of
your code i think these two
taken together if you understand these
in my experience
the if you get these right
the implementation is uh
immunization tends to fall out whereas
if you
if you don't have these right you'll
very quickly produce spaghetti good
um and finally at a somewhat more
philosophical
try to understand what the tool you're
building is supposed to do
and what you can assume and what you and
what you what
what you can assume like what parts of
it you want to leave free
for the user to extend and what parts do
you want to lock down to just do for
them
and this kind of will help define what
the the words
of the vocabulary of this layer you're
building to communicate with the
computer is
um second if you have to build if you've
been tasked with building
a i know a larger system that has many
has many parts
um i suggest you start with the simplest
possible version of this
um you know it's sometimes called gall's
law the idea that all
working big systems were derived from a
working small system
and that when you're trying to prototype
build
the simplest plausible version of all of
your components
that communicate the way you think they
should and make sure they you know make
sure the system holds together
um if you can start from the center and
build out
um
it's very easy if you start from the
outside the user interface and build in
there'll be decisions along the way that
are arbitrary from the
outside but inside need to be coherent
you know beware not to paint yourself
into a corner a question i always ask
during design discussions is uh
not can we do this extension but what do
we see a path to adding this new feature
in the future
as long as you don't paint yourself in
the corner you're probably okay
and also remember keep the end goal in
mind right there
there's no you don't want to build
layers of abstraction purely for the
sake of building layers of abstraction
you want to make sure that all are in
service of
achieving our goal
so uh at this point we've
um all the advice i've said so far could
really be summarized as do good things
which while true is not particularly
helpful or actionable
so if we're going to dig into like what
makes a good layer
uh what do we mean to rephrase the extra
we want to build tools that are easier
to use than the layer below us that
we're building on
and we also need to make sure they're
flexible enough to solve
more than one problem um
you know um
given that we're working in a layered
system you know
we could consider looking at physics as
a sort as a
as a way to frame our thinking about how
to think about complex layered systems
audiophysics has over a century of
effort
by a lot of people to understand like
the layer complexes of this reality
um but it's also what i'm trained in uh
and when you have a hammer everything
looks like a nail so
uh i came to this perfect this practice
with that background so that is the
framing we're going the rest of this
talk we'll use
to try to understand uh how to do
software design
and uh for my fellow physicists
uh it's a bit as a somewhat of a joke i
i'm sure we can find a harmonic
oscillator in here someplace
so a
kind of a universal concept in physics
is this notion of the separation of
scales
and when i say scales here i don't mean
scales of like in the sense of web scale
uh of just like lots of things i mean
there's a separation
of scales where things at bigger scales
and smaller scales
don't can be neglected when you're
working at the scale of interest
um this makes them an intuitive sense
and that if we wanted to compute the
trajectory of kicking a soccer ball
between
you and your friend um
we don't need to worry about the details
of the uh you know
the quarks and glue ones in the atoms
uh of the molecules that make up the
soccer ball
right all of those effects can be
averaged down when you consider the
soccer ball as
one thing right with a soccer ball that
gets kicked
second technically the
you know jupiter away at the edge of the
solar system is applying a small
gravitational pull
to the soccer ball but if the effect of
that is so small
it's not something we have to worry
about and that and in that sense
things at a bigger scale we can neglect
when we want to understand the
ballistics of a soccer ball um
or put another way this this concept of
separation just gives us how we take
the the complete problem of
understanding the world
and getting it down to a problem that
can fit in our head that we can
reason about and it's tractable um
and when you do this it is important to
keep track of what simplifications and
assumptions you've made
so that uh you know where you're
where what you've come up with is
applicable or not
um a really interesting a classic video
from the 1970s
uh it's about nine or ten minutes long
as it uh
starts from uh the scale of a picnic
and then zooms out to the scale of view
of the observable universe
and then zooms down to the scale
of subatomic particles and showing you
all the different scales that exist and
how we can work at each of them
uh separately
uh we have a concrete application of how
we would use like such an effective
theory to describe it the scale of
interest
of interest so say we wanted to answer a
question like
what is what is the pressure of a tenth
of a mole of gas
in a two liter bottle at room
temperature
if we know about atoms we could compute
the pressure by tracking every atom in
the in the container
figuring out how often is the wall and
like measuring the pressure by how much
force was applied
however that requires you know several
yatta bytes of ram
which is more than is i think available
on earth if you got hold of every single
computer and like you're definitely not
doing that by hand it's just
fundamentally intractable
on the other hand we could answer this
question using the ideal gas law which
is an effective theory of
uh gap of gas which tells us that the
pressure times the volume
of a gas in a vessel is equal to the
number of
molecules times the constant r times the
temperature
in kelvin which in this case works out
to 1.1.2 atmospheres then this is the
the real gas law gives us a tool we can
work with
that uh
is useful in its own right it it we can
use it to answer important questions
like is my propane tank strong enough to
survive
in the desert in the summer without
exploding
and these these uh these effective
theories can
either be empirically discovered uh or
derived from the scale below
and the fact that we come at this from
both sides is one of the ways that
physics we use to make sure
that our our overall aggregate theories
hold together
and make sense another
um
thing i've found in physics that when
you approach a problem choosing the
correct coordinate system can make all
the difference
uh if we consider a circle which
in polar coordinates is a constant so r
equals five uh
that's about as simple as you can get in
terms of describing
a curve um if you wanted to parameterize
this we can get x and y as a function of
some parameter
we can trace out that curve as
you know as shown but if you really
wanted this as like a
y as a function of x no we can solve
that
it's multi-valued and imaginary in some
places it is not it's a little weird
like it's not it's not a no
mathematicians will tell us it's not a
true function because it's multi-valued
but you know you can make it work
however if you look at something more
complicated like
what i'm calling a wobble um
in polar coordinates this is you know
r is a function of theta uh
with one trig function that's not bad
um if you wanted to get the the x and y
coordinates as a function of theta we
can also compute that
parameterization again there's there's
more trig functions but it's still
fundamentally not
that bad um however solving
y as a function of x uh it's going to
get messy
i've left it as a uh exercise the reader
if you
want to crank through the algebra to get
there
but as you say that it's looking at the
the graph you can see there's there's
some points where we've got one value as
a function
you know there's one value by one value
for an x that places with two
some places with three and a couple
places with four and that this is just
trying to describe this as y as a
function of x is just not
commensurate with the problem we have um
and you find similar things in software
if you pick
a tools and languages which are well
suited to your problem
it can be easy if you're trying to use
the wrong tool for the job
you'll feel like your tools are fighting
so uh just a quick word about how far we
can push this analogy
right in physics there is an objective
reality uh
we don't really know what it you know we
have a pretty good handle on it but we
don't know
we don't know what the right answer is
right we can only discover it as we go
and really all of our descriptions of
physics are effective theories
because we don't know what we don't know
what the bottom is
um and historically really interesting
science happens
when we start to find failure modes in
those effective theories um
and this is of interest to you i highly
recommend this book uh by sabian hofste
also fielder about the current state
of uh theoretical physics
on the other hand in computers we being
humans
and at large control almost all of these
layers
but basically until we get down to the
the the physics of the transistor we
all of those lay all of those layers and
all the so-called effective theories
between them
are controlled and developed by humans
and that means we can
build almost any effective theory or api
if you will
that you want and we will do much more
freedom
but i still think that this um this
framing of thinking about
the scales and the interfaces between
them is very helpful
pulling this back to concrete terms
quickly
say i say my goal is to get the html of
a web page
uh i can do this with two lines of
python port requests request.get
um and for my
as the usage point of view this is very
simple as two lines of python
however under the hood there's a
tremendous amount of work being done to
make this happen
right there's the dns resolution to
figure out what the ip address of
the sql xkc server is like once we know
that we set up a tcp connection
uh send some bits back and forth you
know some of those bits are going to be
the tls handshake some of the you know
some of those bits are going to be the
http protocol which is a non-trivial
uh protocol
and then if we're feeling particularly
pedantic we can go back
to the that the
the third slide where we go through you
know all the whole stack back down to
you know back down to the quarks on both
my machine and the server
and you know and we haven't even talked
about the network stack yet
um and these details are super important
right like if any of these things didn't
work right i wouldn't get my web page
but from my point of view as the user i
don't have to worry about them because
they are
they're averaged over and hidden from me
and this leads us to another i think a
key idea that's come up again and again
in computer science is this idea that
constraints
are one of the things that give us
freedom and power
right because the the ability to control
something
can very quickly turn into the burden of
having to control it
um right and i think you can trace this
idea back
to grace hopper when she developed the
first machine independent
programming languages this
this idea is i think the core of
dijkstra's famous go-to considered
harmful article
which i it's only a page and a half i
recommend everyone read it
um and there's you know there's more
more recent analogs of this
um nathaniel smithsco considered harmful
blog post
about structure concurrency and
richard hickey's simple made easy talk
about the design
uh philosophy behind closure
so
pushing on this idea of players right if
we accept there's a layer which is a
different scale and below that we don't
we don't we don't know the details
that means we don't have to care about
the details and that means they can be
switched out
without uh without us being affected
you know for example if you're using
copper wire or fiber optics or avian
carriers
to mana to send your your network stack
if your goal is to get a web page you
shouldn't
it shouldn't matter to you how it's done
uh
in the same way that if i want to send
you a picture
if i choose to include that encode that
as a png or a jpeg or a tiff
those details matter and someone has
someone somewhere has to take care of it
but the the action of sending you a
picture is independent of how i encode
it
um these ideas tend to come up in
software engineering are the terms of
like polymorphism and duct typing
um you know and these ideas are
what allow us to do dependency injection
right if i write some code that says i'm
going to take in something that that
has that looks like a python dictionary
right where i have you know
keys and you know and get item and
the items that do what they do on the
python dictionary
any object that matches those can be
used right
and as you start to lock these things
down
this is where we start defining
protocols and standards
and i think that a way to view this is
whenever you have a
standard or protocol that you've defined
you're defining
the edge of a scale right we're below
that
you don't know the details and above
that you can just use the interface
and in addition i think in addition to
convenience and programming i think
standards particularly open standards
are critical for us when we try to tame
the complexity that is computers um
and one of the things they give us is
the ability to work together even if we
don't
know each other or if we do know each
other and don't like each other
um but the fact that every web server on
the planet speaks http
means that every company
you can talk to any company you know and
uh using any browser
similarly like uh because there is a
standard to email
you know you can have email services run
by mutually hostile companies
but still communicate with each other
via those tools um
you know and one thing that has made me
particularly happy
is to see the convergence of power for
peripherals
peripherals converge onto usb uh this is
my box
of accumulated power plugs for
about 18 years of uh
existing in tech
much better if you just said well it's
all just usb um
in particular i think uh open standards
are particularly important because
that's what's going to protect us
as a community from vendor lock-in and
monopolies
so so so far we've all we've been
talking about
what these layers and abstractions can
can do for you
i think it's worth saying what they
can't do um
in in programming complexity is
typically
complexity is conserved right there's
there's some inherent amount of
complexity in a problem
that you can't get rid of right it's
just inherent to the problem
um you know there
you can say that uh if you're trying to
model some real
system like in the real world on a
computer the computer version
has is inherently as complex and more
complex than the system you're modeling
um and very much like the second law of
thermodynamics where you can only
increase entropy
uh in a closed system uh you can only
increase complexity
uh let's say it's all it's all lost like
we can we can move complexity around
that's one of the things these layers
let you do is you can take some of the
complexity and hide it
but it's still there it's not it's not
gone it's just hidden
uh you know you've converted things that
used to be options that you had to
control two things that are now baked in
the tool
um you know as maurice moss from the it
crowd says
i will put this fire over here with the
rest of the fire
um and of course
you can always make it more complex
right there's nothing preventing us from
making
it worse uh just can't make it better
and finally for completeness um
you know abstractions and layers are not
all upside
right they almost by definition they add
complexity to your code um they can slow
you you know
they can reduce your performance because
the you're running things through
interface
um it's almost always going to be faster
to go directly to the layer that your
your abstraction is talking to rather
than talking to it through the
abstraction
um you know as the bitcoin miners have
demonstrated
you know python's usually slower than c
which is usually slower than the same
computation on an fpga
which is usually slower than the same
computation
in a custom asic where that like the
algorithm is encoded in the silicon
uh of course the trade-off is the wildly
the wild increase in
development time uh frequently
implementation details
can leak through to the through the
interface
um frequently in terms of performance
um you know this is why random access
into python deck
is much can be much slower than the same
into a python list
and popping the first element off the
python list can be much much slower
than popping the first element off the
deck and finally
if you use a tool to provide your
abstraction and that tool is just not
good uh you now have two problems
the problem you had and the fact that
your tool is broken
so um one could ask
is there one true abstraction to rule
them all
uh no there's not just
no what tools do for us
is that they they they they're embedding
assumptions about what needs to be done
into themselves
um which reduces their flexibility in
generality
but makes them much more suited for that
one task
um so what's pictured here is a
collection of specialty bike tools
which if you want to pull your your
cranks or
remove your your cassette these are
tools you need
like you could in principle do without
it but it's it's hard i own these tools
like couldn't do it without them
however these tools are almost useless
for anything else because they've
they have their assumptions so baked
into them
in programming the first language the
first tool
that we uh we work with is actually the
language we work in
which is a statement um that
may not be at first you know it may not
be obvious
on its face but as soon as you hear it
it's it's it does seem obvious
um and you're like why did i think of
that sense
um i i recommend you watch these two
talks one by ashley williams the other
by evan
chipsuki um talking about rust
javascript and async
and on elm respectively which really
push on the idea that like a language is
a tool and that tool has
goals and things it was designed to do
and you should use the language for
problems that it is well fit for
um similarly like
the functions and libraries and scripts
interla you know are also tools
and what our job as developers is
is to use these tools to build the next
tool that is better that is
even better suited for what we need
so uh
these tools help or control
how you can express yourself to the
computer right if you want to do the
the task of add one plus one yeah the
the
second thing you do after hello world
see
all the lines of code here do the same
thing right they're all adding one to
one
however they look wildly different right
based on the paradigm and the way of the
language they're written in and like how
how it's structured and these
this choice of spelling has consequences
for
um what you can express easily what
problems are easy
what what thoughts are easy to express
in a language and what are hard
and it's also important remember that
none of these are the like
the right or the correct spelling uh
the python ast which you mentioned in
the beginning is basically a declarative
version
of what the code you wrote here having
converted you know
printing x plus y as ast
and the python virtual machine is a
stack based virtual machine
so python by code is the stacked version
but the and what this comes through is
that the when we write
code we're really not writing code for
the computer we're writing code for
other humans
right the computer can take care of
itself right you can go look at the
obvious ksc competition
or the minify.js that you've almost
certainly pulled from
one of your that's really pulled in your
browser for what like
any major web app these days or any of
the
so-called esoteric languages which
uh you know technically run
and are turing complete uh but are
basically unreadable
um that the people you're writing for
uh are you know are freaking
so you're most are your collaborators
and your most frequent collaborator
is your future or past self depending on
where you want to look
um i personally think past tom is a jerk
uh six months ago tom has left me so
many messes to clean up it's just it's
it's terrible um and i hope i'm not the
only person
who has you know works in a shared code
base and every so often you read some
code you're like this is terrible
who wrote this you check get blame and
you're like oh
i wrote this um
other times your collaborators are your
friends and co-workers
or sometimes they're strangers on the
internet but in all cases
our job as a developer is to use the
tools we have
and then produce new tools which
simplify and structure the problem into
something
that we as humans can read and
understand and reason about
um so
when we start thinking about the overall
system like an overall
ecosystem and and all these layers
a way you can frame this which is i've
uh
this is stolen from a talk peter wang
gave
i think it uh sci-fi several years ago
you can think of this as ions in the
ocean
where the gland above the sea level is
the user application code
and everything below this ocean the sea
level is
uh the the library code that supports it
um and one way we can build this is by
thinking of like building volcanoes up
over time
where you've got some broad base that's
coming up and just the peak sticks above
water
uh and you've got this broad underwater
mountain
a different way you can do this you can
imagine building so-called matchsticks
where you have your application and you
build those very narrow stick
it goes all the way down to the sea
floor this solves your problem
and now if i want to build a second
application uh
you know we can have a second volcano or
a second matchstick
um and if all we're looking at is
application code these are about the
same
however we wanted to build a fourth
island in between this the first and
second
if we have volcano code uh
we only have to build down as far as the
nearest slope
which may be relatively close to the
surface depending on exactly where
it is on the other hand in the mastic
case we have to build all the way to the
bottom again
because there's no nothing's there
and that long term the community of
practice
and open source is that we're building
we're building these shared volcanoes
where everyone uh takes what's there
builds their thin layer on top and
leaves that for the next person just
over time
we use a community build uh
build up and with that i'd like to thank
you for your time
i'm looking forward to talking to
all of you in the uh
the question asks answer sessions and
this is
um just a final list of uh things that i
read while preparing for this
talk that i did not manage to cite
somewhere else
ah have a nice day